[Music]
let me tell you it has been a fantastic
month for deception
and i'm not even talking about the
american presidential race
we have a high profile journalist caught
for plagiarism
a young superstar writer whose book
involves so many
uh made up quotes that they've pulled it
from the shelves a new york times expose
on fake book reviews
it's been fantastic now of course not
all deception
hits the news much of the deception is
every day
in fact a lot of research shows that we
all lie once or twice a day
as dave suggested so it's about 6 30 now
suggest that most of us should have lied
let's take a look at winnipeg how many
of you in the last 24 hours think back
have told a little fib or a big one how
many have told a little lie out there
all right good these are all the liars
make sure you pay attention to them
no that looked good it was about
two-thirds of you the other third didn't
lie
or perhaps forgot or you're lying to me
about your line which is very very
devious
this fits with a lot of the research
which suggests that
line is very pervasive it's this
pervasiveness
combined with the centrality to what it
means to be a human the fact that we can
tell the truth or make something up that
has fascinated people throughout
history here we have diogenes with his
lantern does anybody know what he was
looking for
a single honest man and he died without
finding one back in greece
and we have confucius in the east who
was really concerned with sincerity
not only that you walked the walk or
talked the talk
but you believed in what you were doing
you believed in your principles
now my first professional encounter with
deception is a little bit later than
these guys a couple thousand years
i was a customs officer for canada back
in the mid 90s
yep i was defending canada's borders you
may think that's a weapon right there
um in fact uh that's um
a stamp i used a stamp to defend
canada's borders
very canadian of me i learned a lot
about deception while doing
my duty here in customs one of which was
that most of what i thought i knew about
deception was wrong and i'll tell you
about some of that tonight
but even since just 1995 96 the way we
communicate has been completely
transformed
we email we text we skype we facebook
it's insane
almost every aspect of human
communication has been changed and of
course that's had an impact on deception
let me tell you a little bit about a
couple of new deceptions we've been
tracking and documenting they're called
the butler
the sock puppet and the chinese water
army
it sounds a little bit like a weird book
but actually they're all
new types of laws let's start with the
butlers here's an example of one
on my way anybody ever written on my way
then you've also lied
we're never on our way we're thinking
about going on our way
here's another one sorry i didn't
respond to you earlier my battery was
dead your battery wasn't dead
you weren't in a dead zone you just
didn't want to respond to that person
that time
here's the last one you're talking to
somebody and you say sorry i got work
gotta go but really you're just bored
you want to talk to somebody else
each of these is about a relationship
and
this is a 24 7 connected world once you
get my cell phone number you can
literally be in touch with me 24 hours
a day and so these lies are being used
by people to create a buffer
like the butler used to do between us
and the
connections to everybody else but
they're very special they use ambiguity
that comes from using technology
you don't know where i am or what i'm
doing or who i'm with
and they're aimed at protecting the
relationships these aren't just people
being jerks
these are people that are saying look i
don't want to talk to you now or i
didn't want to talk to you then
but i still care about you our
relationship is still important
now the sock puppet on the other hand is
a totally different animal
the sock puppet isn't about ambiguity
per se it's about identity
let me give you a very recent example as
in like last week
here's rj ellery bestseller author in
britain
uh here's one of his best-selling books
here's a reviewer online
on amazon my favorite by nicodemus jones
is
whatever else it might do it will touch
your soul
and of course you might suspect that
nicodemus jones is
r.j ellery he wrote very very positive
reviews about himself surprise surprise
now this park sock puppet stuff isn't
actually that new walt whitman
um also did this back in the day before
there was internet technology
sock puppet becomes interesting when we
get to scale
which is the domain of the chinese water
army chinese water army refers to
thousands of people in china that are
paid small amounts of money
to produce content it could be reviews
it could be
propaganda the government hires these
people companies hire them
all over the place in north america we
call this astro turfing
and astroturfing is very common now
there's a lot of concerns about it
we see this especially with product
reviews book reviews
everything from hotels to whether that
toaster is a good toaster or not
now looking at these three reviews or
these three types of deception you might
think
the internet is really making us a
deceptive species
especially when you think about the
astroturf where we can see deception
brought up to scale but actually
what i've been finding is very different
from that
now let's put aside the online anonymous
sex chat rooms which i'm sure none of
you have been in
i can assure you there's deception there
and let's put aside
the nigerian prince who's emailed you
about getting the 43 million out of the
country
let's forget about that guy too let's
focus on the conversations between our
friends and our family and our
co-workers and our loved ones those are
the conversations that really matter
what does technology do to deception
with those folks
here's a couple of studies one of the
things one of the studies we do are
called diary studies
in which we ask people to record all of
their conversations and all their lives
for seven days and what we can do then
is calculate how many lies took place
per conversation
within a medium and the finding that we
get that surprises people the most is
that email is the most honest
of those three media and it really
throws people for a loop because we
think well
there's no non-verbal cues so why don't
you lie more
the phone in contrast the most lies
again and again and again we see the
phone is the device that people lie on
the most and perhaps because
of the butler lie ambiguities i was
telling you about
this tends to be very different from
what people expect
what about resumes we did a study in
which we had people apply for a job and
they could apply for a job either with a
traditional paper resume or on linkedin
which is a social networking site like
facebook but for professionals
involves the same information as a
resume and what we found
to many people's surprise was that those
linkedin resumes were more honest on the
things that mattered to employers like
your responsibilities or your skills
your previous job
how about facebook itself you know we
always think that hey
there are these idealized versions
people are just showing the best things
that happen in their lives
i thought that many times my friends no
way they can be that cool and have that
good of a life
well one study tested this by examining
people's personalities they had
four good friends of a person judge
their personality then they had
strangers many strangers judge the
person's personality
just from facebook and what they found
was those judgments of personality were
pretty much identical highly correlated
meaning that facebook profiles really do
reflect our actual personality
all right well what about online dating
i mean that's a pretty deceptive space
i'm sure you all have friends that have
used online dating
and they would tell you about that guy
that had no hair when he came or the
woman that didn't look at all like her
photo
well we were really interested in it and
so what we did is we brought people
online daters into the lab and then we
measured them we got their height up
against the wall
we put them on a scale got their weight
ladies loved that
and then we actually got their driver's
license to get their age
and what we found was very very
interesting
here's an example of the men and the
height
along the bottom is how tall they said
they were in their profile along the
y-axis the up
vertical axis is how tall they actually
were
that diagonal line is the truth line if
their dots on it they were telling
exactly the truth
as you see most of the little dots are
below the line
what it means is all the guys were lying
about their height in fact they lied
about their height about nine
tenths of an inch what we say in the lab
is strong
rounding up
you get to 5 8 and 1 10 and boom 5'9
but what's really important here is look
at all those dots they are clustering
pretty close to truth what we found
was 80 of our participants did indeed
lie on one of those dimensions
but they always lied by a little bit one
of the reasons is pretty simple if you
go to
a date a coffee date and you're
completely different than what you said
game over right so people lied
frequently but they lied
subtly not too much they were
constrained
well what explains all these things what
explains the fact
that despite our intuitions mine
included
a lot of online communication
technologically mediated communication
is more honest than face-to-face that
really is strange how do we explain this
well to do that one thing is we can look
at the deception detection literature
it's a very old literature by now it's
it's coming up on 50 years
it's been reviewed many times there's
been thousands of trials hundreds of
studies
and there's some really compelling uh
findings the first is
we're really bad at detecting deception
really bad 54
accuracy on average when you have to
tell if somebody that just said a
statement
is lying or not that's really bad
why is it so bad well it has to do with
pinocchio's nose
if i were to ask you guys what do you
rely on when you're looking at somebody
and you want to find out if they're
lying
what cue do you pay attention to most of
you would say
that one of the cues you look at is the
eyes the eyes are the wind of the soul
and you're not alone
around the world almost every culture
one of the top cues is eyes
but the research over the last 50 years
says there's actually no reliable cue to
deception
which blew me away and it's one of the
hard lessons i learned when i was a
customs officer
the eyes do not tell us whether
somebody's lying or not some situations
yes high stakes maybe their pupils
dilate their pitch goes up their
body movements change a little bit but
not all the time not for everybody it's
not reliable
strange the other thing is that just
because you can't see me doesn't mean
i'm going to lie
it's common sense but one important
finding is that we lie for a reason we
lie to protect ourselves or for our own
gain
or for somebody else's gain so there are
some pathological eyes but they make up
a tiny
portion of the of the population we lie
for a reason just because people can't
see us doesn't mean we're going to
necessarily lie
but i think there's actually something
much more interesting and fundamental
going on here
the next big thing for me the next big
idea
we can find by going way back in history
to the origins of language
most linguists agree that we started
speaking somewhere between fifty
thousand and a hundred thousand years
ago that's a long time ago
a lot of humans have lived since then
we've been talking i guess about fires
in caves and
saber-toothed tigers i don't know what
they talked about but they were doing a
lot of talking and like i said there's a
lot of humans evolving
speaking about a hundred billion people
in fact
what's important though is that writing
only emerged about five thousand years
ago
so what that means is that all the
people before there was any writing
every word that they ever said every
utterance
disappeared no trace evanescent
gone so we've been evolving
to talk in a way in which there is no
record
in fact even the next um big
change to writing was only 500 years ago
now with the printing press which is
very recent in our past
and literacy rates remained incredibly
low right up until
world war ii so even the people of the
last two
millennia most of the words they ever
said
disappeared let's turn to now
the networked age how many of you
have recorded something today anybody do
any writing today did anybody write a
word
it looks like almost every single person
here recorded something
in this room right now we've probably
recorded more
than almost all of human pre-ancient
history
that is crazy we're entering this
amazing period
of flux in human evolution where we've
evolved to speak in a way in which our
words disappear
but we're in an environment where we're
recording everything
in fact i think in the very near future
it's not just what we write that will be
recorded
everything we do will be recorded
what does that mean what's the next big
idea from that
well as a social scientist this is the
most amazing
thing i have ever even dreamed of now
i can look at all those words that used
to for millennia disappear
i can look at lies that before were said
and then gone
remember those astroturfing reviews that
we
were talking about before well when they
write a fake review they have to post it
somewhere and it's left behind for us
so one thing that we did i'll give you
an example of looking at the language
is we paid people to write some fake
reviews one of these reviews is fake the
person never was at the james hotel
the other review is real the person
stayed there
now your task now is to decide
which review is fake
i'll give you a moment to read through
them
but i want everybody to raise their hand
at some point remember i study deception
i can tell if you don't raise your hand
all right how many of you believe that a
is the fake
all right very good about half and how
many of you think
that b is all right slightly more for b
excellent here's the answer b
is a fake well done second group you
dominated the first group
you're actually a little bit unusual
every time we demonstrate this
it's usually about a 50 50 split which
fits with the research 54
maybe people here in winnipeg are more
suspicious and better at figuring it out
it's cold hard winters i love it
all right so why do i care about this
well what i can do now with my
colleagues in computer science is we can
create
computer algorithms that can analyze the
linguistic traces of deception
let me highlight a couple of things here
in the fake review
the first is that liars tend to think
about narrative they make up a story who
and
and what happened and that's what
happened here our fake reviewers talked
about who they were with and what they
were doing
they also used the first person singular
i
way more than the people that actually
stayed there they were inserting
themselves into
the hotel review kind of trying to
convince you were there
in contrast the people that wrote the
reviews that were actually
there their bodies actually entered the
physical space
they talked a lot more about spatial
information
they said how big the bathroom was or
they said
you know here's how far shopping is from
the hotel
now you guys did pretty well most people
perform a chance at this task
our computer algorithm is very accurate
much more accurate than than humans can
be
and it's not going to be accurate all
the time this isn't a deception
detection machine to tell
if your girlfriend's lying to you on
text messaging we believe
that every lie now every type of lie
fake hotel reviews
fake shoe reviews your
girlfriend cheating on you with text
messaging those are all different lies
they're gonna have different patterns of
language
but because everything is recorded now
we can look at all of those kinds of
lies
now as i said as a social scientist this
is
wonderful it's transformational we're
going to be able to learn
so much more about human thought and
expression
about everything from love to
attitudes because everything is being
recorded now but what does it mean
for the average citizen what does it
mean for us in our lives
well let's forget deception for a bit
one of the big
ideas i believe is that we're leaving
these huge traces behind my inbox and
outbox for email is massive and i never
look at it
i write all the time but i never look at
my
at my record at my trace and i think
we're going to see a lot more of that
where we can reflect on who we
are by looking at what we wrote what we
said what we did
now if we bring it back to deception
there's a couple of take away things
here
first line online can be very dangerous
right not only are you leaving a record
for yourself on your machine
but you're leaving a record on the
person that that you were lying to
and you're also leaving them around for
me to analyze with some computer
algorithms
so by all means go ahead and do that
that's good
but when it comes to lying and what we
want to do with our lives
i think we can go back to diogenes and
confucius and they were less concerned
about whether to lie or not to lie
and more concerned about being true to
the self
i think this is really important now
when you are about to say or do
something we can think
do i want this to be part of my legacy
part of my personal record because
in the digital age we live in now in the
networked age
we're all leaving a record
thank you so much for your time and good
luck with your record
you